Понад чотирнадцять годин дороги. Чотири пересадки. Рушаймо!
Моя мета - більше дізнатися про рух за скасування авіаперельотів
та з’ясувати, чи справді це може допомогти довкіллю.
Я їду туди, де виник цей рух, – у Швецію.
Спершу - з Берліна в Гамбург. Потягом.
Завдяки еко-активістам на кшталт Ґрети Тунберґ
дедалі більше людей замислюються над звичкою до перельотів.
Авіагалузь відповідальна за понад 2% усіх парникових викидів у світі.
З Гамбурга далі на поромі.
Круто, що ми їдемо на поромі.
Цього я не очікувала: потягом, але на поромі.
Потяги не такі шкідливі для довкілля, як пороми,
але переправа – це щось особливе.
Це значно краще, ніж літати.
Чудовий краєвид п’ять годин поспіль.
Тепер – автобусом до Копенгагена.
Втома від дороги.
По усьому Євросоюзу зростає кількість залізничних перевезень.
На швецькій залізниці це також відчутно.
Я не літаю. Так не можна, нам треба це припинити.
Немає жодної різниці, як саме ми подорожуємо.
Ми - лише одна десята одного відсотка населення планети.
Я обираю літак, якщо авіаквитки значно дешевші.
Але загалом намагаюся так не робити.
Із запізненням на дві години, але зрештою ми у Стокгольмі.
Тут рух проти авіаперельотів навіть підштовхнув до появи бізнес-стартапів.
Tagsemester означає "відпустка потягом".
Спершу це була лише група у Facebook.
2018-го кількість учасників з 5 000 підскочила до майже 94-х тисяч.
Для Андреаса Зідквіста та Сюзанни Ельфорс це стало тим самим шансом.
Якщо йдеться про туризм, то маємо бути чимось трохи більшим,
ніж антиспоживацьким рухом, таким собі анти-фастфудом.
Маємо подорожувати більш свідомо,
більше зосереджуватися на новому досвіді або самій подорожі,
а не діяти, як сарана, яка стрибає туди,
куди всі стрибають, і залишає по собі пустку.
Вони пропонують групові квитки на потяг,
продають подорожі на Interrail та влаштовують
конференції для фанатів залізниці.
Засновники проекту вважають себе підприємцями соціального спрямування.
Для них головне – не гроші.
Про існування конкурентів вони в курсі, але вважають себе особливими.
Існують й інші компанії, які продають залізничні подорожі,
але вони й авіаквитки пропонують.
Ми ж серйозно ставимося до довкілля
та ідеї сталого розвитку і віримо,
що люди підтримають наші спільні цінності.
Відсутність податку на авіаційний керосин
та загалом дуже скромні збори за авіаквитки –
лише деякі причини того, що авіаподорожі країнами ЄС такі доступні.
Дешеві рейси по Європі - це спосіб життя,
який сформував ціле покоління.
Із 2008-го по 2018-й рік кількість пасажирів у світі
майже подвоїлася - до 4,37 мільярда - і досі зростає.
Я зустрічаюся зі Штефаном Ерлером.
Він розповідає, що з 2000-го року EasyJet
на 32% зменшила викиди парникових газів.
- Це означає наступне: що більше пасажирів на борту літака,
тим менше споживання керосину на пасажира та на кілометр.
Окрім того, зараз ми літаємо на найефективнішому у світі літаку.
Але слід прагнути більшого.
Це стосується усіх авіаліній.
Викиди парникових газів літаків – лише верхівка айсберга.
Остання ціль подорожі - Ґетеборґ.
Майя Розен 10 років тому повністю відмовилася від перельотів
і прагне переконати шведів до 2020 року забути про літаки.
Поки що безуспішно, та вона не впадає в розпач.
Каже, щоб політики прислухалися, потрібно зібрати підписи загалом ста тисяч людей.
Але поки є 4,5 тисячі.
- Я не надто переймаюся.
Думаю, що ті, хто підписався, відчувають обов'язок переконати й інших.
Тому що ближче до кінця року, то більше людей буде задіяно.
З агітацією Майї Розен допомагає група активістів.
Виявляється, багато перехожих не знають, про що йдеться.
Шведи – одні з найбільших фанатів подорожей у ЄС.
У 2017-му аж 59 мільйонів громадянин Швеції їздили у відпустки,
тобто кожен - по шість разів.
Я не думаю, що люди не готові чимось жертвувати.
Проблема радше в тому, що більшість політиків та вчених
не зовсім ТАК говорять про кліматичні зміни, щоб можна було чітко зрозуміти:
йдеться саме про ТУТ і ЗАРАЗ, і ми повинні стати активними.
Моя подорож спричинила викиди парникових газів на рівні 82 кілограмів.
Із авіаперельотами цей показник був би значно гіршим.
Не можу присягнутися, що більше не літатиму.
Але що точно – ця поїздка змусила мене багато про що замислитись.